(music)
Voiceover: It's pretty
rare to have a conversation
about education policy in which the word
"technology" isn't used at some point.
Occasionally, in the administrative sense,
as a way to make education more efficient;
but mostly in the classroom
sense, helping kids learn.
Which gets us to Salman Khan.
He's a former hedge fund
manager turned educator
as the founder and sole faculty member
of the Khan Academy.
It started as a tutoring service
for his cousins on YouTube.
It's become a library of thousands
of instructional videos on topics
from basic arithmetic to organic chemistry
to the French Revolution
with financial backing from,
among others, the Gates Foundation.
Sal Kahn, good to have you with us.
Sal: Great to be here.
Voiceover: How, exactly, did you wind up
putting videos on YouTube?
Sal: I was a little
dismissive of it at first.
I didn't think YouTube was
for serious mathematics.
I thought it was more
for dogs on skateboards
or whatever else, but I
decided to give it a shot
and people all over the
world started watching them.
Some of them would say,
"Hey, this helped me on an exam."
But some of them would say,
"Hey, this helped me not
drop out of high school"
or "This helped me get into the school
"that I wanted to get into,"
so it became a pretty
exciting thing to work on.
Voiceover: What's the
education problem, though,
that you think this technology can solve?
Sal: It's a pretty
straightforward problem,
is that everyone learns at different paces
and right now everyone's
forced to go at the same pace.
It's a more serious
problem than just people
being bored or people being
lost in one classroom.
What happens when everyone
moves at the same pace is,
you and and I are in the
exam or we're learning
a basic subject; I don't
get 5% of the subject,
you don't get 20% of the subject,
the whole class moves on
to a more advanced subject.
I have a 5% gap, you have a 20% gap.
Those gaps build up over time.
It pretty much guarantees
that most students,
by the time they get
to algebra or calculus,
have so many of these gaps
that no matter how hard they try,
they just can't understand
what's going on.
What we're trying to address
is every student can go at their own pace,
make sure that they master
something before moving on.
When you do that, then
those gaps shouldn't happen.
Voiceover: It's an
accumulation of failure, right?
Isn't that your phrase?
Sal: Yeah, I would say it's
an accumulation of gaps.
The failure thing is
another interesting ...
Right now, when you take
an assessment, a test,
in school, you get a label.
You get an A, B or C or D.
The A kids kind of feel
good about themselves,
they get self confidence.
B students are a little bit neutral.
You get a C, D or F,
it's not viewed as, hey,
you didn't understand 30%.
Why don't you go and try to
learn it a little bit better?
It's viewed as you're not so smart.
Don't try to become an
engineer or a physicist.
Voiceover: Where do you fit in, though?
Where does Khan Academy
fit in in the larger
application of technology to education?
How do you slide in there?
Sal: For a while, whenever people talk
about technology in education
they've just been talking about putting
computers or iPads or whatever in a room
and hoping something good happens.
Even when there was something
to do on a computer,
it was always viewed as separate
from the core curriculum.
It was viewed separate of what normally
goes on in a math class.
What we're saying is now we
can actually use technology,
we can use these videos,
we can use this software,
to allow every student to
work at their own pace.
It's not an either/or proposition anymore.
There's always this debate
of do you do more of the core skills
or do more of the projects
and the investigations?
We're saying that you can do both.
You can use the technology to handle
a lot of the core skills, free up a lot
of the teacher's time to do
more of the human interactions.
Voiceover: For the price
of a login, right ...
You either login through
Facebook or Google,
you get access to all these things.
Is there a thought in your mind
of somehow making people pay for this?
Sal: We want to at some
point be sustainable
as a not-for-profit, but we
want all of this material
to be 100% accessible by everyone.
On the web and our core
tools will always be free.
Right now, nothing on
our radar is non free,
I guess is the simple answer.
Voiceover: What's the next
step for the Khan Academy?
Sal: Right now, we have
about 2 million students
a month who use our
site on a regular basis.
We want to start leveraging them
so that they can help each other.
If you're in a classroom,
your teacher knows that you need help;
but if you're not in a classroom
or you need a supplement to a classroom,
maybe one of the other community members
of the Khan Academy can tutor you
or help you out or get
you passed your hurdle.
Voiceover: Salman Khan.
He's the founder of the Khan Academy.
Thanks a lot.
Sal: Great, thanks.